okay so i know where this this product
begins i know where it ends now we're
ready to put this thing together and
only about 15 of the state got this far
have a look back up here here are my
terms at the beginning right climbing
down from the top of the ladder so if i
zoom out a little bit i should be able
to see that and write it at the same
time hopefully it's big enough for you
guys still to read
i'm going to go
2 n on 2 n plus 1
multiply by i n minus 1 but i know what
i minus 1 is it's it's equal to this
right so therefore i'm going to go
multiply by 2n minus 2
on 2n minus 1. uh what's the next one
it's 2n minus 4 on
2n minus 3 and then this just keeps
going right i didn't bother to work out
what i n minus 3 was but the pattern
will continue and then i'm going to end
up where am i going to end up here's the
second last term i want so it'll be
two-thirds
and then the very last term is
one all right so what do i do with this
thing well as with all proofs uh you
need to have one eye on the the sort of
finish line um as well as one eye on the
thing that you're working on at the
moment so if i go back up you can see
this is what i'm required to prove this
thing here the one that was like uh
gross
how is this i'm just going to copy it so
you can see them at the same place how
is this similar or different to this
result right here
well for me the easiest thing is
actually to have a look at those
denominators we had them in green before
right have a look at these they're very
useful to me
that one on the end it doesn't have a
denominator so let's write it as 1 over
1 so that i do have a denominator there
you go
have a look at the denominators see what
they look like and see how close they
are to what i want but not quite right i
want a 2n plus 1
factorial 2n plus 1 factorial it's like
so close right i've got a two n plus one
i start there and i have a one at the
end there's just a bunch of things
missing from two n plus one factorial
right two n plus one all factorial means
i need to include every single number
all the way down to one
i'm missing a lot of numbers i'm missing
exactly half of them right you can see
there's a number missing in here between
two n plus one and two n minus one there
should be right in here
there should be a 2n right that would
sort of complete the sequence and it's
the same because they step down in twos
they decrease in twos every time there's
a term missing in here as well it'd be a
2n
minus 2. presumably another term missing
here there's even a term missing right
at the very end you've got three and
then you skip two and then you go to one
right so oh this would be two n minus
four by the way so therefore what i
wanna do here is i wanna introduce these
terms into the denominators so that i
can get this 2m plus 1 factorial that
i'm after okay
so how do i do that well watch out this
is going to look a little weird right
let's put in these terms that i want or
rather these terms that i had before
and then what i'm going to include is
these extra denominators that i need to
make the 2n plus 1 factorial appear
right so there's going to be a 2n there
then here comes the next fraction in the
sequence so it's 2 minus 2 on 2n minus
1. and then we're missing a term again
it's the on two n minus two
term and uh then i keep going along and
then i'm gonna have two n minus four on
two n minus three i'll do one more for
good measure just to make it i'm trying
to get this pattern of three right
so i guess the next one would be that
two n minus four that i said before
multiply by dot dot dot uh and then what
have i got two thirds
uh here comes the missing two
and then i've got the one over one right
at the end there okay
so in other words i've included all the
even terms i had all the odd ones before
right one and three and these are all in
the form of an odd number and i've just
inserted all these even ones
but hold up i mean you can see by the
way i've written this line right this is
incomplete you can't just multiply
denominators by something because it is
convenient to you i can't actually
change this product i have to maintain
its identity right so if you are
multiplying the denominator by something
to keep the thing equal you had better
be multiplying the numerator by the same
thing so 2n on 2n
2n minus 2 on 2n minus 2 and so on all
the way down
i'll admit this feels like a bit of a
rabbit out of a hat trick when you just
look at the completed line but i hope
you can see how we arrived at this
conclusion we knew we needed this 2n
plus 1 factorial and we looked and we
were like ah
it's sort of there but i need to modify
it in some way to get it to where i need
so that's why i did this to the
denominators which means i did something
to the numerators as well
okay now i'm just looking at the time i
i don't think i'm going to have enough
time to
get you to work independently again or
send you into breakouts
sorry
but i do want to get you to the end of
this and see the thinking that so much
of the state was unable to make in the
question um so that you'll be equipped
to have a go at questions like this in
the future okay
have a look we have sort of um really
tidied up our denominators they are
exactly what i want so i'm going to uh
sort of write this i'm just going to
duplicate this right
but i want you to notice something has
happened to our numerators at the same
time as something has happened to our
denominators i wonder if you noticed it
can you see because we added in all
these even terms here right
every term that you've added you can
factorize a two out of it right
and all the terms are originally there
the numerators were all the even ones
right so therefore um those ones you can
also factorize a 2 out of so i'm going
to rewrite this line
and i'm going to make that factorization
obvious and i hope you're going to see
why i need this factorization in a
second
2
there's obviously an n another two with
an n and then when you take two out of
this you get think about it
n minus one and then that one repeats
when you have a look at the next one
it's two n minus four so you take that
factor of two out two and then you get
left with an n minus 2 same thing
happens for this one
now why would i bother to take out all
of these twos i wonder if you can see
back on your original piece of working
why this is important look right there
see that that 2 to the 2n means
a bunch of twos were factorized out and
you have to think well do i have the
right number of twos and the answer is
yes how many terms are there in this
entire product we start from one two
three it's just the counting numbers and
we go all the way up to two n plus one
so this entire line has two n plus one
terms in it
but not every term has a two in the
numerator there's a single term right
here that doesn't have a two in it so
even though i've got two n plus one
terms
one of those terms is missing the two so
two n plus one minus that one gives you
this 2m that you're looking for and i
wonder if at this point we are close
enough to the end that it's all fitting
together in your mind
watch this i'm going to factorize out
all those twos how many did we just say
they were
two n of them okay
i can also say on the denominator i did
this weird sort of all of this business
because i can just
ball them up in a single factorial so
i've got 2n plus 1
factorial and then what gets left behind
look at it carefully with me what color
have i not used yet here we go
there's an n an n an n minus one another
n minus one an n minus two another n
minus two and then i've got these guys
hanging out on the end there uh actually
i take that back those have been
factorized out so they're not there
uh what's left behind the answer is
there's sort of these doubles of this
decreasing sequence right let me write
it for you really obviously the n times
n
is n squared the n minus 1 times n minus
1 is n minus 1 squared and so on
and then it's going to keep on
decreasing right
until you get to
2 squared and then
1 squared and then there's the 1 hanging
out on the end there
what have we got here well it's this big
long product and every single term in it
has been squared so therefore i can uh
actually so oopsy daisy i can actually
write that as the whole thing
being squared all of this is just gonna
hang out the front
and then every term that you can see
that i've shunted off the fraction um
the n and the n minus 1 and the n minus
2 and everything
they have all
been
squared
can you see
there it is that's the result we were
trying to prove
2 to the 2n hanging out the front
this this thing here
is by definition n factorial so i'm
going to write that with that color n
factorial
and it's all squared and then on the
denominator shock r we actually got
there 2n plus 1
factorial